remontez quotidienne de 1300 un
établissement de santé
trente mille cent six personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisés pour une
infection qu'ovide 1885 nouveaux
patients ont été hospitalisés
ces dernières 24 heures mais en tenant
compte des sorties le solde reste
négatif avec 478 personnes hospitalisées
en moins par rapport à hier 5433
patients dans un état grave
nécessite une hospitalisation en
réanimation au cours des dernières 24
heures 190 nouveaux malades ont été
admis dans un service de soins intensifs
de soins continus ou de réanimation le
solde reste négatif pour le 13e jour
consécutif
il est de 250 patients en moins en
réanimation dans les outre-mer on relève
98 hospitalisation c'est une baisse de
10 admission de 32 patients en
réanimation là aussi le chiffre baisse
doucement depuis le début de l'épidémie
39 milles 180 une personnes
hospitalisées sont rentrés à domicile et
c'est sans compter les dizaines de
milliers de personnes guéries en ville
sans passage par l'hôpital
vous le constatez cette épidémie est
massive près de 83 mille personnes ont
été hospitalisés pour une infection
qu'ovide depuis le début de l'épidémie
la circulation du virus demeure à un
niveau élevé vous le constatez avec le
nombre d'admissions à l'hôpital et le
nombre d'admissions en réanimation du
devons donc rester pleinement mobilisées